[Musica]
ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e mi sono
appena distrutto una gamba comunque
ragazzi come in ogni sabato siamo in un
nuovo blog è come in ogni sabato
ovviamente iniziamo con la parte della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da andrea che ha fatto un
capolavoro
cioè io ragazzi non vedevo una fan art
del genere da mesi è fantastica ti
meriti di vincere la parte della
settimana e potesse anche quella del
mese perché veramente epica c'è una cosa
impressionante anche ragazzi vi aveva
detto su facebook che in questo blog
avrei detto una cosa abbastanza
importante ma voglio tenerla per ultima
perché praticamente ci sono delle cose
che volevo dirvi prima che sono un po
più brevi
allora la prima cosa che voglio dirvi è
che voglio veramente ringraziarvi per il
200 mila iscritti ancora non avevo fatto
di persona perché praticamente il sabato
scorso invece nel blog è uscito appunto
lo speciale 200mila iscritti e quindi
non avevo modo di non ancora avuto modo
di dirmelo propria parola e quindi
ragazzi veramente grazie dei 200.000 che
ormai sono oltre 210.000 in una
settimana quindi è una cosa mostruosa
comunque grazie veramente e se non li
avessi morto e lato abbastanza coni
grazie volevo ringraziare una persona in
particolare che è giulia gatta che
prevede una ragazza che è un mostro
nelle editing nel senso che è bravissima
ed è stata lei che mi ha creato
veramente tutti gli mb che avete visto
la fine di ogni speciale quelli dove c'è
la musica tutta e tutte le scene che
vanno al ritmo di musica una cosa che io
non saprei fare quindi ragazzi ci tenevo
ringraziarla personalmente per tutto il
lavoro che ha fatto è comunque ragazzi
volevo anche avvisarvi che il prossimo
speciale che uscirà il prossimo
traguardo sarà molto diverso da tutti
quelli che ho fatto fino adesso perché è
una cosa che volevo fare da tempo
932 più avanti la gara non preoccupatevi
comunque vi dico che è diversissima da
ogni cosa che ho fatto fino adesso c'è
una cosa che non c'è davano una mazza
mahdavi spider o niente comunque ragazzi
abbiamo finito le cose brevi da dire
adesso passo la cosa che volevo dirvi
sin dall'inizio nella pagina di facebook
che come ogni video mentre sempre nella
descrizione come dico sempre alla fine
dei video ho postato un'immagine nella
quale ci sono i pavimenti faccio vedere
le mie cuffie
che si sono rotte cioè che vedete sono
spezzate e non ho praticamente potuto
fare video per tre giorni come ho
scritto su facebook e alcuni di voi
pensavano che questa cosa fosse
diciamo una scusa per non registrare per
trovare un alibi per non fare video per
tre giorni per prendermi una vacanza
prolungata in effetti come scusa faceva
abbastanza schifo scusatemi ragazzi è
stato più forte di me
non volevo registrare non volevo dirvelo
e quindi mi sono inventato una scusa
stupidissima per non poterlo fare la
cavi chiedo perdono vi supplico
perdonatemi non avrei mai voluto farlo
[Musica]
ma delle cuffie uguali e le mie sono
anche notte minchia che coincidenza non
ci posso credere
ragazzi è stato veramente un trama
perché per molti per molte persone
queste possono sembrare delle cuffie
normalissime ma per me queste non sono
cuffie normalissime perché queste quale
uso praticamente da quasi da quando ho
iniziato a registrare sul canale fanno
parte di tutto il lavoro che ho fatto
fino adesso quindi ragazzi non
immaginate lo sconforto nel vederle così
e molti di voi mi hanno scritto nei
commenti perché poi alla fine ho detto
ragazzi che prenderò il prima possibile
delle nuove era difficilissimo vedere fa
vige con un altro paio di cuffie
non posso vederlo con un paio di altre
cuffie ragazzi non mi vedrai neanch'io
con un paio di altre coppie c'è non
sarei neanche più io cioè queste fanno
parte di me ormai sono le mie orecchie
come voi sapete è quindi ragazzi la
soluzione è stata una soltanto però
ordinare un altro paio di cuffie è
esattamente identiche a queste qui
quindi ragazzi queste semplicemente
quelle nuove che sono uguali a quelle di
prima non è cambiato assolutamente nulla
crisi ragazzi the news sono finite e
direi di passare all'apertura dei falchi
come al solito in ogni blog che il punto
che aspettate tutti quanti fino alla
morte in ogni sacrosanto blog e questa
volta ragazzi ho deciso di non aprirne
soltanto 12 di pacchi come faccio al
solito ma di aprirne 4 questo perché
ambrì mente losco rosa vi salvo io ho
buttato giù la uil televisore tutto
questo perché i ragazzi lo scorso sabato
non ho fatto il blog quindi direi che
posso recuperare due pacchi che avrei
dovuto aprire la settimana scorsa li
recupera adesso e poi dite che non vi dò
mai ascolto alla ragazzi videos a questa
settimana devo incazzarmi perché non
riesco ad aprile infatti che mi inviate
che sono sigillati più delle casseforti
tornando ragazzi la cosa buffa è che su
stoffa coach è scritto manufatto che
cazzo mi avete inviato un manufatto
cos'è un reperto maya io mi aspetto
grandi cross da questo quindi voglio
sono curiosissimo di vedere del cazzo
c'è qua dentro mi avete inviato un
bambino nava bella gara che cazzo ha ma
poi fa v6 scosso il pacco quello che c'è
dentro ti proseguite la fine in capo al
mondo sappi che se ci avrò sfiga nei
prossimi giorni ti vengo a cercare
chiunque tu sia
sì sì ce l'ho fatta era ciò non ci ho
messo molto meno stavolta cos'è l'asl
and air box che cazzo cielo già uno
slider manichino non me lo avete visto
inviato un altro un altro [ __ ] slider
manichino
ma bastano già un ragazzo o punk hunnam
sta cosa è il diario di maxwell quanto
questo epico caso è questo ragazzo
invece dire che fa bella coppia con
questo qui vabbè questa epica una mini
nutella grazie mille ami non aprire ve
l'avevo detto di non aprire
ecco qui le due dice che ti mancavano da
outlast solo malandate il corpo nel
pozzo maniaco che tela staccate
[Musica]
la mezza giuste fatto che si apre
decentemente l'ho trovato dopo anni
mio zio ma questa è la cosa più etica
che io abbia mai visto
certo e questo è il disegno più
fantastico che abbia mai visto
bovi jazz un mito vice arnova ragazzi
questo è stupendo cazzo c'è un bisogno è
meraviglioso cazzo disegno fatto così
bene non me l'aveva inviato nessuno
grazie mille per solo aprendo di sicuro
da qualche parte adesso comunque vedo
però favi iniziato tutto tra marzo
aprile di quest'anno ero su youtube mi
sono imbattuta per caso in uno dei tuoi
video chiari cosa benissimo essere stato
uomo di previtali su motori dreams
da quel momento si è diventato uno dei
miei youtuber preferiti e ogni giorno
aspetto grazie a un nuovo tuo video
ricaricando ogni 5 minuti la pagina del
canale 61 youtuber formidabile dalla sua
grande fan maria grazie mille ti regalo
la prima e sola copia delle due parate
che ti ho disegnato a ma sei stato tu a
fare queste sì ragazzi queste erano due
fan art che avevo messo dei video
precedenti sono fantastiche grazie mille
6 anche bravissimo a disegnare mi ha
fatto veramente piacere la lettera
grazie mille ragazzi accorge ultimo
palco per oggi perché mi avete inviato
il videogame di csi crew che grazie
mille perché veramente ho sempre sognato
csi new york dei gay dei ragazzi penso
che basti per oggi addirittura note
scatolati 4 l'indirizzo dei parchi
ragazzi nel caso vogliate inviarmi
qualcosa lo trovate nella descrizione di
questo video poi c'è la premessa
l'indirizzo che trovate nella decisione
non è l'indirizzo dove abito no perché
molti mi scrivono primo prodotto ad
andare all'indirizzo che hai scritto
nella descrizione ma lui ti ho trovato
perché ragazzi quelle all'indirizzo del
di una delle poste di torino dove io
vado a prendere i pacchi che arrivano è
un fermo posto non abito lì quindi
inutile che è andato a vedere perché
tanto non mi trovate cioè se volete
andate ma
non pensate di trovarmi ma che non
abitanti abito d'altra parte del mondo
praticamente tirreni passera l'ultimo
punto quindi fa vi risponde la prima
domanda arriva da keira ma vi rispondo e
favi i miti la ragazza di the grudge
io mi sono cagato addosso solo la
seconda domanda arriva da saya calati a
fabi risponde fabio ma perchè non fai
più the witch house alla rega questa è
la cosa che dovevo assolutamente dire
perché è da mesi che continuate a
chiedermi sta cosa prima inter arrivato
a un certo punto abbastanza avanti che
avevo registrato due o tre episodi è
praticamente per un errore del gioco mi
si sono cancellati i salvataggi e quindi
avrebbe richiesto un casino di tempo
quindi non ho avuto più la costanza di
rifarlo daccapo e quindi i ragazzi sono
fermato lì comunque sto cercando
videogame rpg sempre in stile the witch
house vader cosa del genere o c'è
qualche mente qualche titolo ma comunque
se avete qualcosa a consigliarmi che
volete che io faccia quello che mi hai
consigliato di più comunque quello che
riceve più pollici in su ovviamente da
un occhio maggiore di riguarda quello
che mi chiederete di più quindi se avete
un rpg
scrivetelo nei commenti e vedrò se parlo
più avanti come sai che comunque una
serie rpg la inizierò più avanti
tranquilli alberto bat fa vi risponde
suona la chitarra
[Applauso]
ra cro ragazzi non lo faccio perché sono
talmente bene che mi spunterebbe il
copyright sotto il video ma dai ragazzi
di rifinire qui con le domande non fatte
poche perché ode scatolato 12 pacchi e
quindi non c'era sarebbe uscita una cosa
troppo lunga ma anche ragazzi volevo
feci darmi una cosa se scrivete una
domanda abbastanza divertente una cosa
che che volete che io faccia di focolare
la chitarra ovunque cosa tipo quella di
harry potter all'inizio del video
sappiate che io comunque le cose belle
le scelgo quasi sempre perché io quando
guardi commenti viene lasciate 3000 ogni
blog e che ci crediate o no io me li
leggo tutti e di questi tremila ne
seleziona 45 ma non perché devo
selezionarne botti perché ne selezionerà
i anche 50 ma di tutti sti 3 mila in
genere soltanto 45 sono idonei a essere
messi nel blog perché sono abbastanza
divertenti credetemi che se scrivete in
qualcosa di divertente da farmi fare è
tipo scenette come quella di fare i
paesi con cat mario nello scorso blog o
comunque altre cose che ho fatto
credetemi che se descritti divertenti io
la scelgo per forza perché non avete
idea di quanti commenti salto perché
sono cose abbastanza ovvie quindi
ragazzi esprimete la vostra
immaginazione e fatevi una domanda nei
commenti ovviamente potete farmi anche
domande serie questo non lo vieta
nessuno sono anche ragazzi gay che
possono chiudere qui il blog come al
solito stupido è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovato
nella descrizione cells distinti
scrivente perché ci rivediamo non
fossimo video ei ragazzi